hey guys my name is Jess it is the 11th
of November and here's all the biggest
things that happened in gaming this week
first up the six of you who don't have
overwatch yet are totally in luck
because it's playable for free this
weekend Blizzard has announced that's
from November 18 at 11am pt2 November 21
@ 4 p.m. PDT everyone will be able to
play overwatch for free across ps4 xbox
one and pc unfortunately over watches
newest hero sombra will not to be
playable during the free weekend
blizzard added that you will be able to
level up and loop boxes unlock items and
keep all your progress if you decide to
pick up a full copy of the game using
the same account you can check out the
global start times for the free weekend
and instructions on how to download the
game in a story on stage in news that
has been a long long time coming fallout
4 mods may actually be arriving on ps4
for those renounce to that an update for
the game which unlocks mod support will
come out this month on ps4 the developer
have asked patient fans to stay tuned
for updates in related news update 1.8
arrived for fallout 4 this week the
patch fixes a number of bugs and some
crash scenarios you can check out the
full patch notes in our story on games
like Pokemon go is back in the news this
week because of course it is but this
time the reason is a little mysterious
niantic CEO John Hanke told GamesRadar
that Pokemon go will always have secrets
embedded in the app because the studio
is constantly adding them he went on to
say there's one out there right now and
we'll see how that plays up over the
course of the next few weeks thank you
wouldn't confirm whether or not this
undiscovered secret was added in the
game's halloween update which arrived at
the end of October dishonor to was
playable a day early for those who
pre-ordered but it wasn't all smooth
sailing at PC players began to report a
bevy of technical issues it looks like
this might be the same old pc port story
that we're hearing far too often of late
as the same reviews page to dishonor to
has been flooded with reviews from
frustrated players reports include low
and unstable frame rates blurry graphics
and mouse sensitivity issues among other
problems many of these early reviews
claim
the game itself is fun but advise people
to wait for an update to drop them
before putting your money down for the
day and arcane have said they're aware
of the issues and have posted a list of
suggestions to help you get the game
running smoothly if you are having
issues that be sure to check out the
link in a story on site finally n7 day
came and went this week and bioware
explained how they were going to handle
the branching endings of mass effect 3
in Mass Effect Andromeda creative
director Mark Walters alluded to how
they've addressed the ending on Twitter
where he reiterated that Andromeda takes
place 600 years in the future adding we
said 600 years but from when that we did
not say Mass Effect Andromeda initiative
website has been updated with a timeline
of humanity space exploration efforts
covering the period leading up to the
original mass effect before referencing
the launch of the Andromeda initiative
in 2185 this date is relevant because
it's aftermath of x2 but before mass
effect 3 oh the impacts of mass effect 3
would be unknown by the characters in
Andromeda who were placed in cryostasis
for their journey yeah it's all very
complicated this week on site we talked
about how over what you can you recruit
some replays and just gather some
awesome cosplay at pax australia and now
extra life charity stream is live right
now so be sure to check that one out
thanks for sticking with me again this
week be sure to have yourselves a lovely
weekend and I will see you again in a
very sleep-deprived state after my
24-hour Extra Life shift on monday